hello my friends as the end of the year
the end of 2017 is still upon us and I
have done my top 10 favorite movies of
2017 it's time for the top 10 worst
movies of 2017 same rules apply just
please keep in mind this is my opinion
it's not going to line up with your
opinion I guarantee you everybody
watching this is gonna have that thought
of like why isn't that movie on here
other than it being just differing
opinions there are a few reasons I could
pick up one I didn't see it there's
actually a lot of shitty movies this
year that I just didn't see because a
lot of times is like you know what I'm
busy this year I just don't want to
waste my time watching a [ __ ] movie I
feel like that is a pretty
understandable so there were a lot of
shitty movies I just didn't watch which
I'm glad I've because there are a lot of
shitty movies I did watch and I cannot
imagine watching more or it might be a
guilty pleasure thing though the movie
is complete crap there could be a guilty
pleasure element to it I make you the
same promise for this list that I made
for my top 10 best movies of 2017 less
and that is everybody watching this will
disagree with this list at some level
just the way it is but we're all here to
enjoy that's the best I can phrase it
best I can say and as I reveal each one
these are my quick thoughts on the
movies not reviews whatsoever I do have
reviews for every movie listed on this
list those reviews are here on youtube
if you want my more in-depth Lots on the
movies you can search for my name movie
title movie review and you'll find it
monologue is over let's drag these
pieces of [ __ ] down to hell where
they belong starting with hey all right
let's be honest here Flatliners was a
pretty good concept though it is a
remake we were told it was a sequel
because I had Kiefer Sutherland Kiefer
Sutherland was in this movie for no
reason whatsoever
other than the fact that he was in the
original flat liners and though it
started out as an interesting concept
interesting concept became a boring
movie boring movie became a messy movie
messy movie became a disaster by the end
when people start seeing ghosts or
hallucinations and it I was at what
happens when you die a question as
oldest consciousness but they bricked it
9 I'm a big fan of the Resident Evil
games not so much the Resident Evil
movies well Resident Evil 4 back and
Resident Evil 7 anyway the Resident Evil
movies have never represented the
Resident Evil games I don't know why
they have the same title
other than marketability but we got
ourselves Resident Evil the final
chapter I can barely tell you what
happened in this movie because every
action sequence was among the worst
shaky-cam
I have seen in my life I feel like it's
one of those movies where they write it
as they film it like we don't know
what's happening next but the hold on
I'm writing
I'll tell you tomorrow when we start
filming those the saving grace of this
movie the reason it's actually lower on
the listen I thought it would be is
because the upside is it ended the
Resident Evil movie franchise it's gone
supposedly in this day and age you never
know could come back I look at 2017 this
there were some good horror movies that
came out wish your pond was not one of
them and wish applaud like the moment
you realized the main girl in the movie
is actually kind of an [ __ ] you check
out it wants to do a hundred things yet
it does nothing the concept of a messed
up genius scenario that's kind of cool
this movie absolutely is the opposite of
kind of cool again a movie with a clever
concept that feels like it was put in
the hands of a five-year-old and this is
what we got out of it I watched the
trailer two chips and I was like that
looks terrible and I watched the movie
two chips and I was like I was right
I'll give the trailer that at least the
trailer accurately represented how bad
this movie was gonna be man talk about
no chemistry whatsoever talk about
casting swap Jack Shepherd should have
played Michael Penny's character Michael
Pena should have played Dax Shepard
character it was like they're like doing
I want a role reversal can we play okay
let's swap think about a comedy just
make me laugh and you've done your job I
don't think I laugh in this movie I
might have chuckled once it was a
second-rate Starsky and Hutch that I
almost walked out of number six how does
the dude's eyes do it the trailer at the
bar the bye-bye man the screening I was
at for the bye-bye man was in Los
Angeles was a lived in Los Angeles for
the past year and the makers of the
movie they literally looked around at
all these teenagers in this screening
auditorium they were like we made this
movie for a certain demographic and I'm
pretty sure you were exactly what we're
looking for I was like did you just tell
the audience that you think they're
idiots and watch the movie and I was
like no you absolutely positively told
the audience you think they're idiots
from the intro the very beginning of
this movie it feels like a student film
it just never breaks that made for DVD
that's where this movie probably belongs
five I'm actually torn is the emoji
movie a shitty video game movie or is it
just a shitty movie because emojis are
not video games this tried to be another
record Ralph it was a $0.99 wreck-it
Ralph the movie was not only boring it
had boring characters you can just feel
the disconnect between the ones who made
this movie and the target audience
target audience being young people this
movie was made by old people who thought
they could speak to young people they
saw a market and jumped on it without
understanding what the market was I
wanted to give this
via pass because it is made for kids but
what this movie is is cash-grab garbage
marketing that treats kids like morons
Matt is what you feel when you watch the
emoji movie that are ill oh yeah
unforgettable is quite forgettable I
promise you that this is one of these
movies every year or a crazy person
can't take rejection like a champ I
can't just take any so they gotta go
nuts and now we gotta have a stupid
movie every year there's at least one
and here we go it usually has the worst
script worst performances the rumor out
there is no one wants to work with
Katherine Heigl because she's unbearable
I don't know I can't qualify that but
watching this movie I'm like this
movie's not doing her any favors we
haven't seen her in a movie in a while
then she shows up in this thing this
thriller movie is almost a competent
comedy accidentally so it's not it's
neither it's neither thrilling nor funny
it's just [ __ ] alright folks I have a
complex history with Michael Bay because
without him I wouldn't have started
doing videos on YouTube had I not ranted
about Transformers Revenge of the Fallen
I would not be here to tell you
transformers the last night it has not
gotten better it's only just gotten
longer if that's the thing these movies
do every movie butchers the Transformers
lore a little more every movie seems a
bit longer in every movie the humor is
even more awkward but I sit down every
one of these [ __ ] things I'm like
maybe this is the one that's gonna break
the mold it has he's Stanley Tucci
cracking jokes at the very beginning is
Merlin and I'm like nope as catfish and
sewer shark once said here we go again
oh yeah as a deep cut but as far as I
give a [ __ ] these transformers movies
they can just end transformers the last
night does not have the touch nor the
power had david fincher directed the
Snowman it probably would have been
alright but he didn't and I hated this
movie when I watched it and I hated this
movie even more as time went on like
every month every day I was like I hate
that snowman movie even more talk about
a Boris snooze this movie had nothing
going for Michael Fassbender look like
he was phoning it in Val Kilmer's in it
kind of it's a boring murder mystery
that made no sense it had these side
storylines and these side story arcs
that you're like what's the point of all
this it's almost funny how terrible it
is every time I revisited my top 10 list
the snowmen crept up higher and higher
and higher I'll be honest with you guys
your full disclosure once I found out
who the killer was in this movie and
then
watched it horribly choreographed
scuffle I was like you know what if I
leave now I can beat the rush I can beat
the traffic because there's nothing
that's gonna happen in the last five
minutes that brings it home for me so
what could pop out of the screen we love
those big checks and be like Jeremy you
stuck around for the end you just won
ten million dollars I'd be like whatever
your movies still dog [ __ ] can I please
leave and beat the traffic no you
already know what it is really there's
no mystery at this point you know what
this is I'll give you a couple seconds
to realize three two one
yeah fifty shades darker it's as bad as
you've heard it's probably worse this
movie's incompetent on every level
there's no chemistry between these two
is horribly written and I learned after
I watched the movie because I was like
that movie was worse than the first
movie who wrote this thing because the
script is noticeably worse then I heard
that they fired the writer of the movie
and the writer of the books husband
wrote the script or some [ __ ] I don't
know I might be churning out rumor mill
garbage wouldn't doubt it whoever wrote
this script has no business writing
scripts whoever directed this movie has
no business directing film the fun kinky
sex [ __ ] is that even I don't remember
any of that but that's because I've
slowly started to forget about this
movie as time's going on this is
laughable if I wasn't crying on the
inside
this movie is every bit the Twilight fan
fiction it was actually created to be
God to my knowledge they're not
splitting the third one into two movies
so hopefully the third one the next one
is the last one movie came out early in
2017 I was like I have found the worst
until it gets dethroned couldn't happen
nothing could be thrown this time so
that's it these are the movies that I
walked out of going you know what you're
securing one video at the end of the
year called the top ten worst movies of
2017 holy [ __ ] did you guys watch any of
these I hope not I don't generally do
honorable mentions in the top ten best
and top ten worst movies of the year
videos that I do know sleight against
anyone who doesn't believe me I
understand what you do there certainly
could have been honorable mentions in
this video I looked at I was like there
are 15 to 20 possible movies that could
be in this top 10 list so there was a
movie you're like why wasn't it on there
oh it deserved to be it's just you gotta
whittle it down to 10 but for me in my
way it kind of seems like if I was
watching the Olympics and they were like
alright guys here's an honorable mention
or a fourth-place medal you got to be on
the list or you're just not on the list
however I have kind of run into a fun
idea that Stardust app that people are
using if you don't know what it is is an
app called start as you react to a movie
for like 30 seconds or review it you
yourself can review
and I've done a few reviews on there
before this so fun thing I kind of
thought of is in order to not bog down
these videos with honorable mentions I
can actually review the honorable
mentions there and be like hey here's
another honorable mention at the top 10
worst list didn't quite make it but
here's my starters review I put a link
below to my profile and startups could
follow it if you like could be kind of
fun an extension of these videos when
I'm done with the worst I guess I'll do
the best but it's kind of ass backwards
of the way I do it on YouTube but
whatever stuff I like fun new stuff
alright guys so your top 10 worst movies
of the year you gotta whittle it down to
ten point right it's really hard
especially this past year 2017 man it
gave us some shiners well what is your
list of the top ten worst movies of 2017
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]